steigende strom- und gaspreise sie
hängen natürlich mit dem krieg der
russen in der ukraine zusammen und dort
soll es jetzt neue entwicklungen geben
die ukrainischen streitkräfte haben nach
eigenen angaben die angekündigte gegen
offensive im süden des landes gestartet
das zuständige militärkommando süd
teilte am montag mit die offensive gehe
in verschiedene richtungen inklusive der
region um die großstadt kasse die
zivilbevölkerung wurde aufgerufen die
umkämpften gebiete zu verlassen ja und
wir sprechen jetzt mit bild vize points
heime der gerade in japan ist rund 400
kilometer südöstlich der hauptstadt kiew
paul was hast du über diese
gegenoffensive herausfinden können
wir in verschiedenen von verschiedenen
quellen gehört dass sie tatsächlich
begonnen hat denn das war die große
frage heute als die ukraine gesagt haben
sie hat begonnen hat man sich daran
erinnert was seit wochen erzählt wurde
da hieß es immer wieder ja diese
offensive richtung persson die sonne
starten aber tatsächlich ist es so dass
die ukraine in den vergangenen wochen
die bedingungen geschaffen hat um diese
zu starten mit heim us raketen wurden
munitionsdepots angegriffen in der
gesamten region das wurde penibel
vorbereitet ich habe mit einigen quellen
sprechen können die gesagt haben dass
man aus verschiedenen richtungen heute
und gestern in der nacht angegriffen hat
und dass tatsächlich in einem teil der
durchbruch gelungen worden sein soll das
bestätigen auch russische quellen auf
dort gibt es aussagen dass diese
offensive stattgefunden hat und die
ganze stadt liegt das ganze land schaut
jetzt darauf ob es für die ukraine
tatsächlich möglich ist die region um
kassel zurück zu gewinnen das ist eine
wahnsinnig wichtige und auch symbolisch
wichtige region denn herzform das ganz
am anfang des krieges an die russen
gefallen eine wichtige am schwarzen meer
liegende stadt die auch aus
strategischen gründen für die ukraine
entscheidend ist aber dieser kampf
dieser krieg der wird heftig werden und
wird am ende darüber entscheiden ob die
ukraine tatsächlich die kräfte hat ihr
region zurückzugewinnen aus dem
präsidentenpalast gibt es hoffnungsvolle
signale andere jahrmarkt der chef des
präsidialamtes büros hat bereits ein
bild gepostet dass person frei sein wird
ganz sicher allerdings nicht in den
nächsten tagen oder den nächsten wochen
diese mission die kann monate dauern
paul du bist viele viele monate jetzt im
land gewesen in den verschiedensten
regionen des landes wie groß sind die
chancen deiner meinung nach dass das
ukrainische militär ist wirklich schafft
den süden zurück zu erobern
[Applaus]
es ist momentan völlig offen ob die
ukraine das schaffen kann in den
vergangenen wochen das muss man sagen
haben immer wieder experten gesagt das
die zahl der waffen der offensivwaffen
nicht ausreichen würde um so eine große
stadt zurückzugewinnen aber wir hören
von us-geheimdiensten ebenfalls jetzt
bestätigung dass diese offensive
anlaufen soll und dass sie professionell
vorbereitet worden ist und wenn man
davon ausgeht dass die russen
tatsächlich die probleme beim nachschub
haben die probleme haben was die zahl
der soldaten angeht dann könnte das ein
zeichen sein dass das gelingen kann die
taktik der ukrainer ist dabei und das
ist auch schon in den vergangenen wochen
passiert die russen dort einzukesseln
auf eine art zu versuchen brücken zu
zerstören was auch passiert ist und dann
durch zu stoßen und wie gesagt an einem
bereich hat das geklappt jetzt ist die
entscheidende frage was passiert in den
nächsten tagen die ukraine hüllt sich in
schweigen hat totale geheimhaltung
dieser offensive angeordnet also auch
militär reporter diejenigen die sonst
entwertet sind mit der ukrainischen
armee sind nicht in diesem teil momentan
was wir hören ist dass die stadt die
anliegen des staates nikolaev die in der
nähe von odessa ist heute als vergeltung
möglicherweise der russen schwer
beschossen worden ist wir sehen dort es
gibt bilder wie eine brücke dort
angegriffen worden ist es sollen auch
menschen gestorben sein ist sieht
unabhängig davon aus ob diese offensive
tatsächlich funktionieren kann danach
aus dass dieser krieg der in den letzten
wochen soll ein bisschen ja in einem
standort zwischen den beiden zwischen
der ukraine und russland war dass dieser
dort im süden gerade massiv eskalieren
können denn wenn die ukraine weiter
angreifen werden die russen natürlich
versuchen wieder zurückzuschlagen ganz
kurz noch am ende was bedeutet das jetzt
konkret für die zivilbevölkerung wir
haben schon so viele menschen die aus
der ukraine flüchten mussten wie einfach
oder wie schwer wird das jetzt auch für
die zivilbevölkerung diese regionen dann
auch zu verlassen
das ist die große schwierigkeit die
große herausforderung und auch die große
tragödie für die ukraine denn natürlich
beschießen sie jetzt ihre ukrainische
stadt das bleibt ja gar nicht aus werden
sie die zurückerobern wollen und
inwieweit sie da rücksicht auf die
zivilbevölkerung nehmen können und
inwieweit die russen versuchen werden
diese zivilbevölkerung eben in diesen
krieg zu ziehen das ist völlig offen in
jedem fall davon muss man ausgehen wird
es wieder viele tote geben ja tragisch
danke der paul aus mehr paar und du hast
uns auf dem laufenden danke
[Musik]